hey guys dave rubin here i'm thrilled to
finally be able to announce to you guys
that we are officially moving rubin
report to ora TV that's right i'm
joining forces with broadcasting legend
Larry King and free speech beacon Jesse
Ventura Ruben report is going to be
bigger and better than ever before we're
going to keep giving you guys an honest
fun look at the news in a way that you
can understand without all that
screaming you know we've still got free
speech in this country and I'm not
afraid to use it but don't take my word
for it here's Larry King the ruling
report is terrific television we're
happy to welcome dave rubin to aura tvs
going to be with us for many years to
come it's great television and it's free
speech check out Ruben report on ora TV
coming soon and that's a cut go for Wow
Larry that was that was really great
okay there you go thanks thanks so much
for them and that's it I didn't notice
was free speech thank you both so much
good job everybody thank you stay here
you want to keep it there's no Larry